to all the people who have waited
patiently for my thorough review thank
you came out in America today so here we
are
that being said here we go so I had to
say it like that
all right so Thor is a Marvel comic
about the Nordic god of thunder which
makes him probably the most difficult of
Avengers to do that being said did they
pull it off yeah so Thor was living the
good life he was an Asgard he was a rock
star he all comes back from war like yes
how we do it as guard America
I mean Asgard he was like if Kratos from
God of War had a kid with Johnny Cage
needless to say I like the character
Thor now the trailer made it looked like
he got cast out of Asgard because of
something he did but I thought that it
was one of those things where he did
what was right and Anthony Hopkins
didn't understand that because he was
like you know an old man and a fool as
Thor calls him but as it stands the Thor
was pretty arrogant and stupid actions
lead to consequences and his arrogance
got him kicked out kicked out of his
home down to earth so that he's down
here with no powers he needs to get his
powers back because his brother Loki's
taken over and we all know how
mischievous Loki can be okay I cannot
hear Loki and not think of a mask for
ever now kenneth branagh the director
was asked how did you do this I mean
usually you're like all Shakespearean
now you're taking on a comic book movie
his response was that it's all the same
stuff you know like family and rivalry
and exile brothers betrayal and blood
feuds and he's really right it is all
that stuff which makes it really
interesting these gods are really
relatable to us people which is really
hard to do and the trailer Thor says of
natalie portman like he comes from a
world where magic and science are all
the same thing and they did a really
good job showing that as you old saying
goes magic and science are
indistinguishable to affirmative culture
and in Thor's world ask are there pretty
indistinguishable you see stuff you're
like is that science or magic ah they're
both cuz we're primitive people so I
thought that was really cool and I will
say this when Thor is at his lowest low
you really actually feel for the guy I
felt bad for most like to use that
sucks I empathized and felt bad for the
god of thunder god of thunder who's also
a badass warrior which shows in the
action scenes when Thor's throwing down
dude it is badass I do this hardcore
apparently the god of thunder is the God
of War when all these action scenes are
going down you're like it's just so big
this movie kicks off the summer season
in a really big way here's like that
looks expensive
yet the movie has heart which again
usually doesn't happen it's really hard
to do and how's the chemistry between
the god of thunder and a human chick
was great I thought they had really good
chemistry Natalie Portman's character
was actually a really cool chick I'm not
just saying that because you know I'm
halfway in love with her and all that
she was actually a really good character
and likeable and fun and hot so good
chemistry between the main characters
are really devious villain you kind of
see even though he's a villain
it's Thor's brother so Thor doesn't hate
him you just got to stop him which makes
that all the more tragic good great
action sequences and the summer movie
season kicks off with a huge bang I will
say the summer movie season hasn't been
kicked off this well since Ironman one
so apparently the toughest part of the
Avengers lore is done and it's done well
my only real issue with the movies that
I wanted to see more Thor stuff I wanted
to see him be a badass more a lot of the
time it's like a human being although
you do get the moments of him throwing
down all badass but I understand why
they didn't do it because you don't want
to deplete the currency you see it too
much so you're not going to appreciate
it when you do see it screw it I'm going
to go ahead and say Thor is awesome
tacular I didn't think I was gonna
relate to these characters they're so
beyond me kind of but not really they
are and yeah there is something at the
end credits all these Avengers type
movies have something after the credits
so stay till after the credits you have
to Thor seems to be a really important
part of the whole Avengers setup thing
but it also stands strong as a
standalone movie it has elements of
Avengers stuff in it but it doesn't feel
like an Avengers pretty cool that's
really important and that was awesome so
have you seen Thor yet what did you
think of it did you like it did you hate
it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you